[Music]  Pied Pipers well-known this season for a  new video chat app and that's where the  season sort of leaves off is you've  invented this chat app and it's taking I  was doing well we decided to give it a  try and maybe connect with a viewer  right now using the Pied Piper it's  getting a call from me jingyang in  Silicon Valley this is very exciting  let's even get up hello hi is this a mr.  wall a mr. wall no no where is a mrs.  wall no there's no mrs. wall here either  I know I I think you have the wrong  number so there's a no laws in your  house no your roof is going to fall down  and you're going to die alone  that's the most bone-chilling call I've  ever seen  and you are going to die alone  you